while turning now to George Clooney's
relationship with the mall he's
revealing even more details about their
love story and his initial thoughts
after he found out he was going to be a
dad to twins
holy bleep I'm a parent I hope I don't
screw this up
those were George's first thoughts after
a mall gave birth to Alexander and Ella
yep the guy who used to struggle with
loneliness and insomnia now says my
house is filled with the warm sounds of
babies crying but do mr. and mrs.
Clooney want more a most answer is no
quote I'm 39 I already had them quite
late we learned a few things and
George's new interview with The
Hollywood Reporter a mole got pregnant
without the help of fertility drugs
having twins was a shock quote I kept
thinking there was a mistake
George's nickname for a mall is moola
that's what her parents call her he does
perfect husband things like give her
massages and changes the diapers small
says the thing that surprises her most
about Georgia is quote what a great
father he is and as for marriage well
George confesses he has one regret quote
I'm sorry I was fifty something when I
fell madly in love but only because I
could have spent even more time with her
so yes at 56 Georgia still the sexiest
man alive
all-time sexiest man which he makes you
call him when you have - excuse me -
time old man alive excuse me
right now Clooney is making the rounds
with that Damon and Julianne Moore
promoting suburbicon he hasn't acted in
two years so with these leaving on foot
well George simply says quote as you get
older the parts aren't as interesting
I'm not a leading man anymore
nobody wants to see me kiss the girl